To settle with you guys for defeating me.
Oh yeah, forgot, I gotta battle the Bohrok-Va first.
Yes!
Let's battle, Makuta.
Get him!
Why do I always have to say that to you weaklings?
Big bully.
I may only-
I don't have a protective surface to cover my krana, but I can still beat you.
Um, let's see.
What is it?
Seven to go.
For both of us.
Alright, let's battle some more.
This guy is easy.
Oh yeah?
Well, I got the mask of- I got the krana of strong defense shielding.
Let's go, you big bully.
Dance.
Ding, dern, ding, dern.
Psh.
It's Layvok.
Yes, my little brother has failed, but I won't fail.
You remember me from last time.
Oh yeah, you're the annoying one.
Mwako will have to go.
Conra, you're back.
Conra, don't let him eat your mask like that.
Ha, too slow.
You won't see me underground.
Not very much.
I have one more krana, but I'll make this count.
It will only make it harder for you to battle.
We're the second Bohrok to settle with you.
And Bohrok Vah.
Sorry about that.
That's okay, big bro.
I am the tallest Bohrok Vah.
But I can still get you, Makuta.
Ha, you two only have three krana.
Yes, but we're a threat.
You'll soon find out.
I'm one of the most unbeatable Bohrok Vah.
On your faces, Mwako.
Now he's got an open spot.
Protect it.
Yes, I can fling my krana at you.
And that's devastating.
Onewa gave me a hammer.
And it looks just like his, only it's made of different stone.
Now you're more vulnerable to attack.
Hold my hand so I can have it back.
Man, your mouth is really slimy, duh.
Protect the mask heads.
Especially the empty ones around me.
You trained me a bit, so I know how to deflect with my shields.
Now I can just pick these masks off merrily.
It is working.
I must use something.
There's nothing you can use, Makuta.
Failed.
It's part of you.
You're the one-
No.
We did some research and found out that-
That-
The krana belonged to Galak.
But we have krana anyway that are good.
The same number of krana as the last Borokva.
On account, um, new Vokva.
I will, big bro.
I'm gonna use my hammer.
Um, hammer head.
It's sleeping.
Not anymore.
Hm?
Broke his control cable.
Alright.
Time to battle.
I like this one better than M'waka and Kon'ra.
It obeys better.
Brach it, bro-
How'd you like that trick, Makuta?
That's for all the masks that you got back.
Krana flame!
No, wait a minute.
Like, you-
You call that cheating?
Like, so-
You don't even know what cheating is, Makuta.
Now, it will obey me.
It will fail.
Punch in before it takes over.
New Vokva.
You're the one with low defense, isn't it?
Aren't you?
Yes, I am.
But I'll defeat you anyway.
Let's battle.
Why is it so it doesn't attack me?
Wanna see some cool moves, Makuta?
No.
They're boring.
Yeah, you only think they're boring when they're not even yours.
Smash kick.
Super drilling attack.
One of the most powerful Borok.
Ready, Makuta.
I'm gonna meditate for my next move.
Now, get ready.
Because I found out how to do it.
Let me meditate some more.
You know that I also have a bit of electricity power in me.
And magnetize.
Magnetize!
It's a good thing this thing can't attack me.
It's wearing off.
Off its stinger.
I use my air crime.
Time to stop this earthquake.
It's giving me a pain.
But it's my most powerful.
I can't use electricity anymore.
Trick, Makuta.
But that's not enough.
Inferno!
No, I chose to be the fourth in the lineup.
But I'm not battling yet.
Because...
Um...
Uh...
Tarnok Vah's got a battle.
And he has many Chrona.
Hey, what's that one?
It's the Radar Chrona.
I can...
I can talk all I want and know what you're gonna do next.
Darn it!
Hey, that's the Eternal Fire-
Yes it is.
And you won't have anything to do about it.
Now, let's battle.
Light Vision Chrona.
I don't like the look of that.
That was my super head bash.
Super head bash.
Fire Head Strike.
I'll show you like that.
Now I get to fly in the air longer.
And I get to-
Oh, thanks, Nuvok.
I get to open up the ground with electricity.
I can fly.
Oh, thanks, Nuvok.
I've never seen one like that before.
Yeah, just gonna throw that in there.
This is Macutea.
Okay, Macutea.
See?
It works.
Attack me.
Shhh.
Yes, but let him attack you.
I don't like you.
Shhh.
Eferno.
That floor stings.
Alright, I'll command you.
Secret.
Now I'm going to have to use my Radar Chrona.
Let's battle.
Look into my you will not attack me
To the fire weakling. It's taunting me
Yes
But between our last battles, I've earned some chrono
So now I have two and I'm still the most powerful Bohrok
And why didn't you go last?
Shut up close up this Canyon close. I am supposed to my crime. Yeah, Tim with the super punch
This guy's just the pain last time is he is this time and he's got more lives
Can you do that because I'm powerful perfect, huh? I still have it in
Yeah, I'm my little brothers. Um, let's see if it works really get my brother a new one
I'm a CUDA no more of this form
Yes, and that's a good for a good reason
And I'm a stinger
Well, at least this part's powerful. Oh, yeah
What makes up of it? Yes, I do
stopping the energy from the old body
darn it, I
Feel so
Unfortunately for me the power will come back after we after I defeat you you won't defeat me
Unlike what you did in the last one. I
Will defeat you you don't have a chronic. I don't care
What and
galak va
for rock var first
Doesn't know let's special can let her take off the . Yeah, that's all her
Use the buzz saws
Sit him with the super with the super red use confusion quickly or confusion never beat us
You are a weakling and you don't talk
Hey, I saw
dirturr
This one's my favorite.
The solar beam.
Charge up for it.
Water elements are weak to electricity and grass.
So I use a thunderbolt.
She only has one corona left.
Use confusion.
Use super confusion.
That got her good.
She's still able to get up after that super confusion.
Or should I say psychic attack.
Punch her.
Battle her.
Keep her off the middle.
Why do they shoot in the sky like that?
Galak battle her.
I remember this is the tricky one.
Use the dryer beam.
So she slows down.
Make sure she doesn't get it.
I have my night scene mask.
Makuta isn't the last evil.
They're more like our kind.
And they just are bad.
We gotta destroy them.
The only people in the super family that are capable of doing this are the Toa.
I'm not sure.
We're going to have to destroy them someday.
And that's my secret I've been trying to tell you.
The only way for the Toa in Turaga to defeat all twelve swarms of Bohrok and Bohrok-Vah
then they're going to have to find the Exo-Toa.
What's the Exo-Toa?
It's a giant robot.
It's capable of firing missiles and slashing.
Whoa.
Is it really big?
Yes.
It's bigger than most of you.
Bigger than Aoki Aoki.
And it's big mode, of course.
Well, that's my secret.
That's all you've been worrying about?
Yes.
It is.
It's just that I'm not sure the Toa alone will be able to destroy them.
But we'll have to take a chance.
That's my secret.
She only has one more krana.
But you don't have any masks.
No, I don't.
See, I've trained Nui-Rana since the last match.
Turaga loses her krana.
Good job, Nui-Rana.
I have been defeated.
Bohrok and Korok-Vah, you're the ones with all those krana.
Yep.
You want your krana?
It's hard getting out.
I think mine and the white one, aren't they?
Yeah, I think.
Let's get a hard start by using, by using, Scott, by using, um, explosion to knock her
krana out.
I could get a break.
Or a vacation.
Shielding that.
Shielding krana.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Darn it.
That's all I say.
You already told us that in the last battle.
Grr.
Shut up in this battle.
Thanks for telling me to shut up.
Thanks for showing up again.
This is my shielding one.
The other one was my conversation.
Help beam.
Use confusion.
Quick.
And then knock off her krana.
Mask one soon.
Krana.
And now when you do confusion it won't effect.
It'll effect on you.
I don't believe that.
Battle her!
Knock her krana out!
Confusion right when she puts her mask on.
I'm gonna put on my.
This mask.
Now I can control you.
Ready.
Set.
NOW!
Here's confusion.
It's not effecting her!
Alright.
Knock her krana out.
While she has her hands over her eyes.
I got it now. What is it? I can't see it through your mist
Kind that can control other
Put on a block screen
Putting on a block screen
Sir I am putting on a block screen
Now you won't be able to get me ha now the box screens off
I'm super hyper beam. I think it was a little too late
Cuz I already got a chronic
Didn't affect her whenever I say knock her chronic out. It falls out
Knock her chronic out
It's not working
She's gonna shoot. Oh, she's got a strength chrono on
Use confusion quick
It's not working on Korra ah because of the strength Karna
Jun
Super confusion is now off
stupid
Knock her chronic out. Okay people not the super family has
That the super family has defeated a cold moon
Let's go
Doctor senior yes the most powerful the super family
Your wrongdoings will end here
Makuta
Let's battle and I have a speech to announce
Message for all that died from Makuta who have died you will be avenged
Right here at this spot, and I swear that Makuta will perish
he will be gone and
He will no longer rule and he will be the last
evil
Besides the Bohrok besides the swarms of Bohrok Bohrok swarms will be taken care of I swear that right now
But Makuta will be taken care of here. I swear that
he
Will
Be gone and his wrath will be gone from the earth. How'd you get so little I?
Went back to my normal
size
huh
You mean yes most of the super
but that mean but that means that
Stacy is taller than you know she
Know she was in her giant mode many of the people in the super family were in giant mode
We just didn't want to tell you that
Up until now, but you won't get a chance to get revenge on them
but now
Now
This I am ready to defeat you Makuta. This is my best warrior battling suit
Now let's battle
Get him get him again
But tactic is the beam attack is very powerful, but nothing compared to this
Attack wasn't enough Makuta. You don't know how high my health is. You're smarter Makuta
I've noticed that as I watch the others battle
I'm the winner
Go dr. Seigneur. Thanks parak. Bah watch this. It's my super defense move
Must be slick must be slippery must be smooth
You're too
what he's too slippery to bite. Oh
Come on. Let me let me try. I have more teeth must be slick must be slippery. Must be smooth
Hey, how'd he do that?
Hmm see that's my defense move
move now let's battle some more now now now now now battle use the hyper beam
no use the hyper beam on him it knocked out most of the people in the super
family yes it's still in my hands why cuz I'm the most powerful in the super
family usually use the star going back on all right I'm going on a fighting
rampage you're defeated it's pretty good but that was weak I was battling my
weakest throughout this entire battle so when you thought you had the advantage I
actually had the power but now I will destroy you
doctors let's battle Makuta and we'll settle this one and four
oh
now we have finally defeated dr. senior I still have many many many mint more
minutes of battle left in me I will destroy you Makuta in the sky the worst
evil I have ever met the only evil that has been keeping slaves you are not the
worst evil but you are the most cruelest evil why thank you
my last words to you Makuta
foolish
you look toilets
you've also created slaves enslaving your own sons
look here
dammit
you genius
in here
starving
nothing from you is kept a secret now look what you have done to your sons conra look what i have done to him because you made him battle and muraka your best son why would you do this to them
they were just worthless no they were not worthless they were good fighters i found that out all of a sudden and i knew that they weren't pure evil because you have enslaved them they will gain eternal life if i ask permission from jesus up in heaven they will gain eternal life because you have enslaved them and they have battled me good
now look what you have done to your only son
sons do you realize what you have done you have killed them and if i let them go on you they destroy you now this is for all that you have enslaved destroyed and taken the life from makuta you will meet your due today and right now
you and your cowardly acts to make other make
you and your cowardly acts to make other make others fight for you
it is a spirit bomb it will combine with the sky that the others have been using
get him or doom what are you doing you know that power ball in the sky yes
oh great i'm getting the explanation i want
that was meant for you to be gone i contribute this moment to make a boy
now that power ball in the sky it will combine with my most powerful attack
when i fire it and you will be gone and no more evil besides the bull rock will
even will ever walk all seven continents of the earth no buts makuta you will be
be destroyed at this at this place right now and in front of your sons who are about to
die i gotta rebuild these guys what happened um i defeated you in a battle badly but why
did you build us back together i thought you'd never ask you see your father enslaved you
and i pitied that so i built you guys back together and if you promise to not hurt anybody
i can let it be like this we promise now go eat something good you've been eating all
the garbage maybe that will make you better fighters maybe i'd invite you on the team
maybe now get out of here you little rascals the super family has defeated me
get away rodent oh oh no he dead bye bye we go find somebody play
coco didn't battle remember oh yeah she's sick yeah so that's why we could have destroyed that
fast um well we did destroy him anyway yeah that's all that matters well because you you didn't come
back upstairs to uh do some laps around the az but that will be easy it'll be easy for piglet
oh it's getting sort of late too the babies are already in bed
how sweet that nice where's grandma pizza oh you left her in katya's lair oh yeah
we'll go go go go i'm gonna make some snacks shish kebabs all right i'll drive over to the kitchen
Still doing your homework, Stacey.
Too much.
Well, don't worry.
Summer's in this tier.
Get up.
Stacey?
You're the second one up, Alkioki.
Oh, I thought I was the first.
I'll go cook breakfast this morning.
Yeah, you do that.
I'll be down soon.
Escort.
Help Alkioki.
Okay.
You don't really need to wear a kama.
Only during special occasions.
Okay.
I'll go get some food.
Yeah, I guess so.
Hey, wait up.
Let's see.
You need to finish your models.
Yeah, Dan needs to finish them.
Then the kids can play with them or something.
No.
Now, what do you want to do?
What do we got?
We can organize something.
I don't know.
Well, hey, why don't I go take out the trash?
Yeah, you do that right now.
All right.
You're not doing much stuff in this morning.
That's not good.
Yeah.
Now, you two.
You go climb trees or something.
Yeah.
You go around that building that Pyroco made.
You guys need any help?
No.
Just stand me up and get him out of the sink.
It's really boring.
But Stacy isn't up.
I know what I can do.
Pyroco, are you finished?
Yeah.
I'll put you away.
I'm finished.
Well, you certainly must have not had anything much to do.
Nope.
I didn't.
Okay.
I'm really tired now.
All right.
Got to go wake everybody else up.
Well, how do you like your new can tow, Honda?
It's great.
You guys fit in there perfectly.
I guess somebody's up.
I hope that's Stacy.
I know.
Who's up up there?
Um, who wants to battle with the fake Makuta?
I do.
Get your shoes out of the way.
Okay.
Hey, wait a second.
Who has any masks on except Kohatu?
You're the only one that's battling.
He doesn't talk.
I updated it.
I'm going to steer his back now.
I'm ready to get him.
Yeah.
You do that, Kohatu.
Kohatu, you ready to battle?
Yeah.
Okay.
You go ahead.
I'm going to get out my gold mask.
I want to use a different mask now.
Get out my silver mask.
finished it's time to stop yeah it is oh yes I've got oh yes I've got the pink
mask before a black mask after a purple mask all right now I need to paint
another one before a black mask before a black mask brown mask before a black
mask before a black mask after a gold mask before a black mask after a blue
mask I think I should do this I really don't think so I could mold masks that'd be
different yeah but then again I gotta charge them
and there's a gold mask now what else could I do I could paint these types
how
would I paint these types how would I paint these types how would I paint these
different I think I should do this I could paint these types
green that effected mask yeah no I'm not using that painting in
but see before a black mask after
before a black mask Hey yellow bass before a black mask a red mask No
Now what else do we paint?
Okay.
Before a...
Hey, that's primary colors.
Neat.
Before a black mask.
After a gold mask.
Ah, I guess that's Stacy.
I guess that's Stacy.
Before a black mask.
After a silver mask.
Now what else do I paint?
What other kinds of paints do I have?
What kind of paint?
I guess I don't have any more colors from the howl mask.
I guess this is all the colors I can make.
Okay, I'll put them back and I'll start painting another kind and then I'll stop.
This will put a new look to it.
Alright, one more type.
I need to go get my paint.
Okay, I'll paint a...
I'll paint two types, I guess.
I'll paint a...
I'll paint cow cow mask.
Let's see what we got here.
We got extra white paint.
Alright.
We got a black cow cow mask first.
Now let me paint it.
Okay, before a black mask.
After a blue mask.
Before a black mask.
After a white mask.
Got a lot more different colors for this.
Before a black mask.
After a green mask.
Hey, wait a minute.
That's a Toa Kayita color.
Those are Toa Kayita colors.
Cool.
I don't have any more colors.
This kind.
Except gold and silver.
What's wrong with that flashing?
This back...
I guess that's Stacy up there.
Come out.
There.
Now I can put all these back and start painting a new color.
Let's see what type I'll paint.
Wait a minute.
I'll paint...
Should I do a Kaku or...
Do a Kaku.
Should I do...
I'll do a...
Let's see.
I'll do the Akaku.
Now I'll do the Akaku.
I'll do Katama.
No, Miru.
Okay.
What should be my starting color?
I don't have any Miru masks.
Okay.
Before a black mask.
After a red mask.
Let's see what we get.
There's pale green.
Now, let's see what else.
Oh well.
I'm tired of painting the mask.
So I'll just put them back.
That's just as well.
I finished a lot today.
Nobody's up yet.
I guess I'll try a bugle call.
Louie, can you put a bugle call for us?
I guess he's asleep.
Now that is just dumb.
Is anybody here?
You guys finished with the breakfast yet?
Yeah.
We just need to let it sit in the oven.
Well, you guys just get back to doing your chores and stuff.
Gotta go.
That's our show.
But before we go, here's a message from Doctor Senor.
Doctor Senor.
This is Doctor Senor.
Is this thing on?
This is Doctor Senor in the AC.
Now, I have a special note to make.
Join us in our next video.
Beware the Bohrok.
Which the Toad won't be fighting, that is so.
Wait up.
Not the Shelf.
It's in the can.
We had last time when the camera was on while we were cleaning up.
Here's the Shelf.
There's nothing to clean up.
Here's the Vader.
Pick up the camera and let's go.